brought to you by total war Warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free whether you're a total war
veteran or a complete new come into the
series total war Warhammer is
introducing a whole bunch of new
critters and magic which will be a first
for everybody now since we asked once
buy total world Warhammer this week I
thought we get into some of the coolest
most unique and weird as critters you'll
be able to call upon in battle in the
new game first up let's talk about the
Empire our human faction and the
impressive lumenok of fish the lumenok
of Hesh is a magical weapon Zoltar that
builds energy using an orb of sorcery
and unleashes a concentrated beam of
soul fire that can target a specific
unit and take out some of the largest
foes on the battlefield here it is
taking out a giant C handy this is the
thing you'll want to point out all the
other big nasties I have on this list to
save yourself a lot of losses if you're
playing as the Empire since we're on the
subject let's talk about one of the bad
guys you'll want to be pointing your
lumenok at and that is the Terra Geist
while flying units on the whole are a
brave new world for the total boss
series this one really does deserve its
own section in this video for the
uninitiated Terra ghosts are giant
dragon sized bats who are known for
hunting horses at caravans and pegasi
luckily for you they're more than happy
to squash in or whatever and whoever you
point them at due to their sheer size
the tear-gassed can work its way through
an entire group of enemies and it's
excellent at closing the gap to take out
those pesky ranged foes who are trying
to exploit to the complete lack of
ranged units in the vampire counts
faction to make use of one of the
strangest ranged units in the game
you'll naturally need to be playing as
the greenskins
we made up of barbaric orcs and goblets
once upon a time and devaron goblin
tribes needed a way to scout ahead and
somebody decided the best way to go
about this was to launch one little dude
high in the sky with a catapult this
evolved into a pretty formidable warfare
unit as goblin fanatics volunteered to
Don homemade wings and soar into the air
with the aim of crashing into an
opposing force the crazy critters who
wear pointy spy any hats for elevated
destructions then ends up killing a
bunch of enemies and inevitably
themselves you can actually control the
goblins trajectory in total war
Warhammer once they're airborne so if
you're happy to get a little dizzy
you'll be all the more likely to hit
your mark
the dwarves may be little but they have
a bunch of units that want nothing more
than to bash you to smithereens and
they're pretty good at it
particularly if you're under literal
fire from the alien drake's eye on
drake's are dwarves armed with Drake
guns which expel a massive molten blast
onto their foes as you can imagine waves
of fire are pretty damn effective
against most enemies particularly swamps
of little vulnerable ones these fire
cannon wielding dwarves also have beard
Armour because to not have beard armor
while you're shooting fire inches from
your face would simply be ridiculous
while there are a ton of total war
Warhammer creatures that are worthy of
this video the demographics are
definitely among the most regal and
elegant the demogroup Knights are your
quintessential proud and Noble Empire
creatures the monstrous cavalry are half
eagle and half lion and are mounted by
Empire Knights they can pin enemies down
and tear them apart and as if they
weren't tough enough they arrived in
super fancy armor making them a real
pain in the ass to take down finally
arachnophobia where because we've got
spiders and these ones really will hurt
you despite living in Australia I'm
still not a fan of giant spiders so it's
not exactly how I'd like to get around
but some of the stranger breeds of
goblins prefer to ride spiders into
battle specifically the massive and
devastating Arachne rock spider fighting
under the green skin banner the
arachnoid can flatten entire
enemy groups with its sheer size and
stabby little legs a raccoon or rock
spiders smashed through enemy lines
breaking formations with their sheer
mass while savage goblins by accrued
poison-tipped arrows from the platforms
on the slightest gigantic abdomen I mean
it Danny in that comment section which
of these you're a fan of or if there's a
creature you're came to use that I
didn't end up mentioning in this video I
will catch you again soon